le conseil jeu
de la réunion procès
où sont implantés les
sucre dès lors le musée historique
contacter une association de sauvegarde
du patrimoine l'association cham
chantier histoire et architecture
médiévale pour engager est programmé une
opération globale de valorisation de cet
ensemble patrimonial témoignage de
l'architecturé industrielle encore
présentes sur l'île mais en voie de
disparition
une campagne de travaux et mis en place
dans une démarche de conservation du
site
en prenant en compte le traitement du
bâti dans son intégralité et le respect
de son authenticité
privilégiant avant tout le réemploi des
matériaux existants prenant aussi en
compte une dimension sociale le chantier
s'inscrit également dans une démarche de
formation et d'insertion professionnelle
destiné à un public de proximité de
jeunes adultes ou des personnes en
situation de chômage de longue durée
il n'exclut pas toutefois le bénévolat
associant parfois ponctuellement le
milieu scolaire ou les centres de
loisirs au cours du chantier qui se
déroule sur quatre années de 1991 à 1994
des interventions sont entreprises
conformes aux méthodes applicables aux
monuments historiques
le nettoyage et de déblaiement du site
permettent une meilleure lisibilité des
différents bâtiments de cuisine et
l'identification de zones distinctes de
production les travaux de maçonnerie
sont engagés qui moyen âge taille des
pierres en demie pour assurer la
consolidation et la stabilisation des
ruines